- Welcome back to Understanding Quantum
Information and Computation.
My name is John Watrous and
I'm the technical director for IBM Quantum Education.
This is the sixth lesson of the series and it's the second lesson in
the second unit of the series, which is on quantum algorithms.
In the previous lesson, we discussed the query
model of computation, and we saw that in that model, quantum algorithms can
provide a striking advantage
over classical algorithms, including an exponential advantage in the case of Simon's problem.
Unfortunately, the query
model doesn't really have any direct or immediate
practical relevance.
The notion of a black box is a very useful
abstraction as it turns out, but we have some work to
do if we're going to apply
the insights that we've
gained from the query model to a more standard computational setting where inputs are given as strings of bits
rather than as oracles or black boxes.
The main purpose of this lesson is to establish a foundation
from which we can do that.
Here's an overview of the lesson. For much of the lesson, we're going to be focusing
on computational cost,
or in other words, how difficult different
computational tasks are and how we can measure that difficulty.
Roughly speaking, this translates to how long we have to wait
for computations to finish and ultimately which
computational problems
we can solve and which
ones are beyond our reach.
We're going to start with
a couple of examples. Integer factorization and computing greatest common
divisors or GCDs for short.
These are very good examples for illustrating the
underlying principles, and they also both happen
to be highly relevant to Shor's algorithm, which we'll
discuss in the next lesson,
so we'll effectively
get double the mileage out of these examples.
Then we'll discuss the notion of computational costs more generally and how we can measure it.
There are many different
ways that this can be done, but we'll focus pretty
narrowly on how we can do this with circuit models of computation,
specifically Boolean circuits
and quantum circuits.
The focus here will be on algorithms as opposed to computer
hardware, for instance, and we'll be more concerned
with how the costs of
running an algorithm scale as the specific problem instances it's run on grow in size rather
than on how many seconds,
minutes, or hours some
particular computation requires.
The idea that motivates this point of view is that algorithms have
fundamental importance.
To this day, we're
still running algorithms that were developed a
very, very long time ago and very naturally, they will be deployed
against larger and
larger problem instances using faster and more reliable hardware as technology develops.
And the way that they scale tells us a great deal
about how useful they are and how useful they'll continue to be.
In the last section of the lesson, we'll turn to a critically important task, which is running classical computations
on quantum computers. The reason this is important is not because we hope to replace classical computers
with quantum computers,
which seems extremely unlikely to happen anytime soon if it ever happens, but rather because it opens up
many interesting possibilities
for quantum algorithms.
Specifically, once we know how to run classical computations
on quantum computers, they become available to quantum
algorithms as subroutines
so we can effectively
leverage everything we know about classical algorithms in the pursuit of quantum computational advantages.
The classical computers that we have today are truly marvels of technology.
They're incredibly fast, but they're not so fast that no computational problem
is beyond their reach.
Some computational problems
are so inherently difficult that although we do have
algorithms to solve them, no computer on the planet Earth today
is fast enough to run these
algorithms to completion on even moderately sized inputs within the lifetime of a human
or even within the lifetime
of the Earth itself.
To explain further, let's take a look at the
integer factorization problem.
The problem statement is very simple. The input to the problem is an integer N that's at least two, and the output is the
prime factorization of N,
and what that means is a list of the prime number factors of N together with the powers that these prime numbers must be raised
in order to get N by
multiplying them all together.
Of course, we can always multiply the prime factors together in any order, but aside from their ordering,
prime factorizations are always unique for every choice of N.
That fact is called the
fundamental theorem of arithmetic, and if you're interested
in learning more about it, it's something that you can find
at the very beginning of
many books on number theory.
As a very simple example, here's the prime factorization
of the number 12.
It's two to the power two
times three to the power one.
Not surprisingly, a
computer can tell you this in the blink of an eye by simply searching
iteratively for prime factors.
Here's another example. I won't try to read this number.
It's about 3.4 quattuordecillion, and I have to admit that I find it strange that there's even such a name,
but anyway, it has 46 decimal digits and here you can see
its prime factorization.
A computer can also tell you this. I factored this number using the factoring method that's included in the symbolic mathematics
library for Python,
and it took a few seconds, which is not a particularly long time, but there was a noticeable delay.
And certainly the factor N method doesn't find this prime factorization by naively searching for prime factors.
It actually uses a hybrid
of different algorithms including one called the
colored row algorithm, which is an algorithm for factoring
that's more sophisticated than naively searching iteratively
for prime factors, and although that might seem
like a pretty large number,
as an input to a computational problem, it isn't really all that large at all.
It's only 46 characters.
Here's one more example. It's a number with 309 decimal digits.
If we write it in binary notation, it has 1,024 bits and that's
why it's called RSA1024.
The prime factorization of this number is not currently known.
This number comes from the
RSA factoring challenge, which was run by RSA
Laboratories from 1991 to 2007.
They offered cash prizes
for the prime factorizations of various numbers of increasing
size, including this one, which was worth $100,000 US,
but that prize was never collected.
The security of the RSA
public key crypto system is based on the difficulty
of integer factorization.
If you can factor, you
can break the system, and so the purpose of the challenge was basically to track the
state of the art in factoring.
The bottom line is that
factoring this number is beyond our current abilities.
As far as we know, the
problem itself is too complex for classical computers
to solve in practice.
The largest RSA challenge number to have been factored so far, by the way, has 250 decimal digits.
It might be a little bit hard
to read this on the screen, but here's the prime
factorization of RSA250.
It was done in 2020 using an algorithm known as the number field sieve, and it was a collective effort involving tens of thousands
of computers around the world.
Now, let's consider a different
computational problem, which is the problem of computing the greatest common
divisor, or GCD for short,
of two non-negative integers.
Here's a statement of the problem. The input consists of two
numbers this time, N and M,
and we're gonna assume that
they aren't both equal to zero.
The goal is to compute the
GCD of these two numbers, which is the largest integer D that evenly divides both N and M,
and if you think about the
prime factorizations of N and M, what you'll find is that the GCD is the product of all the prime numbers
that divide both N and M raised to the minimum of the powers that appear in the two
prime factorizations.
So it's related to the problem
of integer factorization, but it turns out to be much, much easier
for computers to solve. We can compute GCDs for numbers with many thousands of digits
in the blink of an eye.
It's kind of pointless for me to try to show you examples on the screen because we could fill the
entire screen with digits and we'd still be describing
easily solved instances of this problem.
But if you're interested, follow the link in the video description to the textbook page for this lesson and you'll find code cells
for the sorts of computations
that I'm talking about, including ones that compute
GCDs of large numbers, and you can try them out for yourself.
The question is why is this possible to compute GCDs so easily?
And the answer to that question is that we have efficient
algorithms to compute GCDs.
Among them is Euclid's algorithm, which was discovered over 2,000 years ago, but there are also other
efficient GCD algorithms.
And of course we're talking about classical algorithms here, so that leads to another question.
Could there be an efficient
classical algorithm for integer factorization
that would allow us to factor numbers like RSA1024
in the blink of an eye?
And the answer is yes. Absolutely there could be an efficient classical
algorithm for factoring and currently we don't know any way
to rule out that possibility. All that we can say is that
we haven't found one yet.
For all the classical
factoring algorithms we know, we're still essentially
searching for factors
and that puts numbers like
RSA1024 out of our reach.
Efficient GCD algorithms,
on the other hand, just don't work that way.
They don't search for a
greatest common divisor. They effectively just build
it with a mechanical procedure that's roughly comparable in cost
to multiplying the same
two numbers together, and I'll say a little bit more about this later in the lesson.
Of course, this is all building
up to Shor's algorithm, which we'll see in the next lesson, which is an efficient quantum algorithm
for computing prime factorizations, but we still have some ground
to cover before we get there.
Next we're going to talk
about a mathematical framework through which we can measure the computational costs
of different algorithms,
including ones we've already talked about.
To be clear, we're going to be focusing very narrowly on circuits, which is just a small piece
of a much broader subject.
Let's start with a very high level view of an ordinary computation
from the previous lesson, meaning in particular that we're not thinking
about query problems,
we're thinking about
problems where the input is given explicitly as a binary string.
Like I said in the previous lesson, we could of course allow
other symbols if we chose to, but let's just keep things simple and stick with binary strings
for both the input and the output.
The computation itself could be modeled or described in a variety of ways such as with the Turing
machine model of computation,
Boolean circuits, quantum circuits, or programs written in
a language like Python or any other language of your choice.
Like I said a moment ago, we're gonna be focusing on
circuits, Boolean and quantum.
First, let's spend a little bit more time talking about the input and the output, which we're assuming are binary strings.
Using binary strings, we can encode many different sorts of
mathematical objects, such as numbers, vectors,
matrices, graphs,
descriptions of molecules, for instance, as well as lists of all of these objects and other ones as well.
As a very simple example, if we wanna encode non-negative
integers as binary strings, we can use binary notation.
Here in this table, you'll see the first 13
non-negative integers along with their binary
representations or encodings.
Here in the third column, you can see the length of
each of these encodings, which is just the total number of bits you need for the encoding,
and here's a simple formula that tells you exactly how many bits
are needed in general for any non-negative integer N.
Notice in particular that
the length of the encoding is generally much smaller
than the number itself.
It's logarithmic in the number.
RSA1024 for instance, has an encoding with length 1,024, but the number itself is of
course much larger than that.
This encoding scheme works
for non-negative integers, but if we want to handle
arbitrary integers, including negative ones, we
can simply tack on a sign bit.
We can also allow any number of leading zeros in these encodings if we want the encodings
to fill out a block of bits or a register of a fixed size
as long as it's big enough. Sometimes that's very convenient.
This isn't the only way to encode integers as strings of bits.
There are other ways that you could do it, but this is a pretty
standard way to do it.
For other sorts of objects that might form the inputs or the outputs to the computational
problems we're interested in, we can come up with
other encoding schemes.
For example, think about how
you might encode a vector or a graph as a binary string or think about how you might encode
two binary strings into
a single binary string using just the symbol zero and one without a space or any other symbol
to separate the two strings. There are certainly ways to
do these things, and in fact, we have a lot of freedom
as to exactly how we do it.
Often there won't be a single standard or universally agreed upon way to encode whatever thing we're talking
about as a binary string,
but that's okay, we can just pick one or we can invent a new one if we prefer.
From a purely formal viewpoint, we're thinking about computations as essentially mechanical transformations on strings of bits
and the specifics of whatever
encoding schemes we use are certainly important at some level.
But nevertheless, when we're designing and
analyzing algorithms, we usually don't worry all that much about the specifics of
the encoding schemes.
If you ask two different people to come up with a way to encode, say, molecules of a certain
type as binary strings,
you might expect them to come up with different ways to do it, but if these were reasonable people who knew what they were doing,
you could also reasonably expect that it would be a pretty
simple computational process to translate back and forth between the two encoding schemes,
most likely requiring a very
straightforward computation that would be quite easy compared to the actual computation
we're interested in.
The bottom line is that the details concerning the encoding schemes we use are often quite secondary and our focus is on the
algorithms themselves.
None of this is going to be an issue for this lesson, by the way. We're mainly gonna be focusing on problems that concern integers, which we'll assume are encoded in binary,
but it's something to be aware of.
In general, for whatever sort of problem we're talking about, the input length refers
to the number of bits we need to encode the input,
and we view the input length as being the size of the instance of whatever problem we're thinking about.
Now, let's consider
the computation itself, which is represented by the
blue rectangle in this figure.
The way that we'll measure
the cost of this computation is to count the number of elementary operations that it requires.
Intuitively speaking, an elementary operation is one involving a small fixed
number of bits or qubits
that can be performed quickly and easily like competing the and of
two bits, for instance.
At a formal level,
there are different ways to define what an elementary operation is, depending upon what
computational model we're using.
For example, an elementary operation could be one step of a Turing machine if we were using that model.
For the purposes of this lesson, we're gonna be focusing on circuit models, as I've already stated, and specifically quantum
and Boolean circuits.
When we're working with circuits, it's typical that we think about each gate as representing an elementary operation.
We've seen several different quantum gates thus far in the series,
including X, Y and Z gates, Hadamard gates, S and T gates,
controlled NOT gates, swap gates, Toffoli gates, and Fredkin gates.
We also talked about query gates in the context of the query model, but we're not going to be working within the query model in this lesson, so we won't worry about
query gates for now.
We also saw that any unitary operation on any number of qubits
can be viewed as a gate if we want to do that.
For the purposes of measuring cost though, that's not going to be very helpful, so what we're going to do is we're simply going
to pick a set of gates
and we'll view that set as being our set of elementary operations.
First, we'll include the
single qubit unitary gates that you see here,
namely X, Y and Z gates,
Hadamard gates and S and T gates, as well as their inverses
or conjugate transposes.
We don't actually need all of these gates. As soon as we have Hadamard and T gates, we can implement the rest of them,
but just for the sake of convenience, we're gonna include all of them.
We'll also include controlled NOT gates, and these will be the only
multiple qubit gates in our set.
And finally we'll include single-qubit standard basis measurements so that we can actually get some classical information
coming out of our circuits.
If we focus just on the unitary gates and forget about the
measurements for a moment, we obtain what's called
a universal gate set.
What that means is that
any unitary operation on any number of qubits can
either be implemented exactly
or arbitrarily closely
with a quantum circuit built out of just these gates.
In other words, this is a
good enough set of gates that we can build any unitary
operation out of them.
Not necessarily exactly, but we can get as good an
approximation as we want.
That might require a lot of gates, and it's actually not too hard to reason that it must require a
lot of gates sometimes,
but nevertheless, it's always possible.
It's not a simple matter to prove that this is a universal gate set though, and we won't discuss how
that's done in the series,
but it is a pretty well known fact and there are in fact different
ways that it can be proved.
There are also other gate sets that are sometimes used
instead of this one, such as Toffoli gates, Hadamard gates, and S gates in addition to measurements,
but this is a pretty standard choice.
So in summary, these are
the quantum operations that we'll view as being elementary.
For Boolean circuits,
we're going to consider these four gates to be
elementary operations: AND gates, OR gates, NOT gates and FANOUT.
FANOUT, by the way, is not
always counted as being a gate, but it's going to be
important for us to do this as we will see later in the lesson.
Similar to what we had for
our standard quantum gate set, this set is a little bit redundant.
You don't need both AND and OR. You can create either one using the other with three NOT gates,
but it doesn't hurt to include both and it's just convenient.
As you may already know, this is a universal gate set
for deterministic computations, meaning that any function
from bits to bits
can be implemented with a Boolean circuit composed of gates from this collection.
Once again, just like we
had for quantum circuits, this doesn't mean that every function can be implemented efficiently
by a Boolean circuit,
and indeed most functions
can only be implemented with very large circuits
for the simple reason that there are lots and lots of functions
and they can't all have small circuits. There just aren't enough
small circuits to go around.
Universality is easier
to prove in this case than in the quantum case as it turns out.
So if you don't already
know how to prove it, give it some thought and
see if you can figure it out if you're so inclined.
Now that we've decided on the
gates we're going to allow and we're going to consider
to be elementary operations, we can think about how many of them
are required to perform
various computations.
To do that, we'll make
use of this definition for the size of a circuit.
This definition works for both
Boolean and quantum circuits and it's very simple.
The size of a circuit is the
total number of gates it has.
For example, if we return
to the same example we've seen several times, which is our Boolean circuit for computing the exclusive OR of two bits,
we see that it has size seven
because there's seven gates, two FANOUT gates, two NOT gates,
two AND gates and one OR gate. If we decided not to count
FANOUT gates, which is common, it would have size equal to five,
but we are going to count FANOUT gates, so its size is seven.
The size of a circuit
corresponds to the number of elementary operations
we need to perform.
So if we were to perform
those operations sequentially and the size would tell
us how long it would take,
so you can think about a circuit size as representing sequential running time.
This is going to be how we
measure computational cost for the purposes of this lesson.
There is another property
of circuits though that can also be viewed as the amount of time
required to run a circuit, and that's the circuit's depth.
To be precise, the depth
is the maximum number of gates encountered on any path from an input wire to an output wire,
which is equivalent to the number of layers of gates we need
to create the circuit, where a layer refers to a bunch of gates
that could be performed simultaneously because they don't have
any wires in common.
For example, our circuit
from before has depth four, and we can see directly from the diagram that there are four layers.
The FANOUT gates can be
performed simultaneously, the NOT gates can be
performed simultaneously and the AND gates can be
performed simultaneously as well.
So we can think about circuit depth as representing parallel running time.
Circuit depth is certainly an interesting and important notion and there are some very
sophisticated techniques that can be used to reduce
the depth required for some computations, sometimes quite dramatically, in fact, but it's an advanced topic
and we're not gonna have too much more to say about it in this series.
So once again, we'll
measure computational cost in terms of circuit
size or in other words,
the number of elementary operations required to perform a computation.
At the beginning of the lesson, we talked about the integer
factorization problem and we saw that the time required for an algorithm to solve this problem
can increase as inputs grow in length, and this is typically
the issue we focus on
when we're analyzing algorithms.
That is, we're interested in how the costs of running algorithms scale as inputs get larger and larger.
Of course, this sort of scaling isn't the only thing that matters.
For example, we may simply be interested in finding the factors
of RSA1024 and that's it.
So in a case like that, we'd be talking about a
single problem instance where nothing is growing.
But when we're thinking about algorithms, the way that their costs
scale matters a great deal and it tells us a lot
about the algorithms.
This point of view is
consistent with the idea that algorithms are fundamental, and as I talked about before,
as time goes on and technology advances, they will be deployed against
larger and larger inputs.
But notice that while inputs to computational problems
can grow in size, circuits don't grow.
Each circuit has a fixed size.
And for that reason, if we want to describe an
algorithm using circuits, we're actually going to need a family of circuits to do that,
and by a family of circuits, we mean a collection of circuits that gets larger and larger so that we can accommodate inputs
as they get larger and larger. For example, let's consider a classical deterministic algorithm
for the integer factorization problem, maybe one based on trial division, but the specifics don't really matter
for the sake of this example.
We could in principle
describe such an algorithm using a family of Boolean circuits where if we want to factor a number
whose binary representation has N-bits, we grab the circuit CN from our family and we input the number
that we want to factor
into the input bits of that circuit.
Sometimes we might choose to parameterize these
circuits in different ways, so it might not always be the case that the Nth circuit has N input bits,
but that's a pretty typical way to do it. Naturally, as the input
lengths get longer, we would expect the circuits
in this family to get larger
reflecting the fact that
factoring four bit numbers is a lot easier than factoring 1,024 bit numbers, for instance.
And so, with that in mind, we measure the cost of such
an algorithm by a function, which tells us how many
elementary operations
we need for each possible input length, and we can do this for both classical and quantum algorithms.
As an example, let's consider the problem of integer addition, which is certainly much
simpler than factoring
or even competing GCDs.
Just to keep things simple, let's suppose that both N and
M are non-negative integers and that they're represented
by binary strings having the same length.
How might we build Boolean circuits that add these two numbers together?
Well, let's start with an algorithm, the standard algorithm for addition, which is the base two analog of the method
that I presume we all learned for adding numbers together with a
pencil and a piece of paper, so we start with the
least significant bits,
add them together, and that gives us the least
significant bit of the result along with a carry bit
that we have to consider
when we move to the next position. And we continue moving through the bits, generating output bits
along with carry bits
until we get to the end.
This method can be
expressed pretty directly in terms of Boolean circuits.
One way to think about it is to start off with a small circuit for adding two single bit integers together.
That'll give us a number
between zero and two, where the lesser significant bit is the XOR of the input bits
and the more significant bit, or the carry bit if you prefer, is the AND of the two input bits.
Sometimes we refer to a circuit that performs these
two operations together as a half adder.
That works fine when there
are just two input bits, but if we want to add together integers with more than just one bit each,
we're going to need to deal
with the carry bits somehow.
So what we can do is to cascade
two half adders together and take the OR of the
carry bits they produce to create what's called a full adder,
which is basically a Boolean circuit for adding three single
bit numbers together.
And once we have a full adder, we can add numbers together
simply by cascading, proceeding from the least significant bit
to the most significant bit. We're basically just implementing the standard addition algorithm using the full adders to
deal with the carry bits.
So what's the cost of this computation?
Well, we need seven elementary
gates for each XOR gate, which means 10 gates for a half adder
and therefore 21 gates for a full adder, which is two half adders plus an OR gate.
So at the end of the day, if our input numbers both have AND bits, we need a half adder for
the least significant bit
and a full adder for every other bit, and the end result is 21 times N minus one plus 10 or 21 N minus 11 gates in total.
If we decided for some reason that we didn't want to
count the FANOUT gates and we included the XOR
gates in our gate set, we'd need five N minus
three gates in total.
It's nice to know exactly how many gates or elementary operations are required to perform different computations,
such as we just saw with integer addition.
And of course, if we actually want to implement these computations, we need to know these details.
But if we always go into this much detail, especially for more
complicated algorithms, we'll be very quickly buried in details
that in many cases have
secondary importance.
One way to simplify matters that's very common in the
analysis of algorithms is to make use of big-O notation,
which allows us to express
and compare rates of growth in a pretty simple way
that's very convenient.
And here you can see the definition that underlies this notation.
Suppose that we have
two functions G and H, which we can think of as taking non-negative integer
values for simplicity,
although that's not actually required. Maybe G and H represent costs of different computations, for instance.
We then say that G is big-O of H, which is traditionally written
with an equal sign like this.
If G of N is at most some
positive constant C times H of N, so long as N is large enough.
So this is about what
happens when N gets large.
Formally, what large enough means is that there's some choice of N zero so that the inequality is true
whenever N is at least N zero.
The key here is that these
numbers C and N zero are fixed.
They can be any numbers at
all, but whatever they are, they can't change as N grows.
If you've never seen this
kind of definition before, it might take some getting used to and you can find resources
that will explain this concept
in a lot more detail than
I'm able to in this lesson.
Usually what we do is to choose
the function H to be simple in order to express something about how quickly the function G grows.
For example, the function whose value is 17 times N cubed minus 257
times N squared plus
65,537 is big-O of N cubed, and you can fit this
example to the definition
by picking C and N zero appropriately.
For example, if we take C to be 18, then we'll have that
the expression is indeed at most 18 times N cubed
as long as N is big enough.
Tying this notation back to the
example of integer addition, what we can now say is that there exists a family of Boolean circuits
for adding non-negative integers together such that the size of the N circuit, meaning the one that works
for inputs of length N
is big-O of N. The actual size of CN
according to our analysis was 21 times N minus 11,
but that's big-O of N.
Now it's not always a smart thing to do to throw away details like this, but here it makes sense
because it reveals the essential nature of the standard addition algorithm, which is that its cost scales linearly
in the size of the numbers
that we're adding together, and this expression is not sensitive to some of the low level
details of our model,
such as precisely which gates we consider to be elementary operations.
For instance, if we decided that XOR gates should be considered as
elementary operations or that FANOUT gates shouldn't
count as gates or both,
we'd still have that integer addition can be computed at cost big-O of N.
Here's another example of
a computational problem, multiplication of integers.
Similar to addition, we can ask what the cost
of this computation is.
If we consider the standard
multiplication algorithm, meaning the base two analog of the method for multiplying numbers
taught in elementary schools,
which is basically just
shifting and adding when we're working with numbers in binary, we find that there are Boolean circuits having size big-O of N squared
for multiplying N-bit integers.
I won't go through this one in detail. Of course the circuits are a
little bit more complicated than the ones for addition, but if you think about the way
that the standard
multiplication algorithm works, it shouldn't come as a surprise.
In essence, we need to
do roughly N additions, each of which has linear cost, and so we end up with
quadratic cost overall.
This can be generalized. If one of the numbers has N bits and the other one has N bits, then we need circuits of
size big-O of N times M.
Here, by the way, we are actually using an extension of the big-O notation where we have multiple variables, but it can be extended like this,
and if you're interested
in the specific details, I'll refer you to the textbook
content for the lesson, which again is linked in
the video description.
It's actually possible
to multiply together two N-bit integers in a way
that's asymptotically superior to the standard multiplication algorithm.
In particular, the Schonhage-Strassen multiplication algorithm
multiplies two N-bit integers with a cost of big-O of
N times the length of N
times the length of the length of N. So as N gets large, like
tens of thousands of bits,
this is actually a more
efficient way to multiply, but it's complicated and the overhead does make it impractical
for smaller numbers.
So let's add multiplication
to our list of examples.
And just for simplicity, let's list the cost given by the standard multiplication algorithm, which is big-O of N squared.
So once again, we're focusing on the essential nature of this cost, which is that it scales quadratically
or sub quadratically if we use asymptotically superior methods.
We can also consider the
problem of integer division, which is stated precisely on the screen.
Here we're talking about computing a quotient and a remainder, so the answer consists
of two integers, Q and R.
Once again, there's a standard
algorithm for division and it also has quadratic
cost and like multiplication,
there are in fact asymptotically
superior algorithms.
So how do GCD algorithms compare?
Well, Euclid's algorithm turns
out to have quadratic cost, and that's what I meant
earlier in the lesson when I said that we can compute GCDs
at roughly the same cost as multiplying two numbers together.
Once again, there are
asymptotically superior algorithms along similar lines to
addition and multiplication,
although the cost is a little
bit higher in this case, as least as far as we know.
I'll mention just one more example of a problem to add to this list, and that's modular exponentiation.
Here there are three input
numbers, K, M, and N, and the goal is to compute
N to the power K modulo-M,
which means the remainder
after we divide by M.
It's not at all obvious, but we can compute modular
exponentiation at qubit cost, meaning big-O of N cubed
for N-bit integers.
The way to do this one is not to first compute N to the power K and then compute the remainder.
Even writing down into the power K could require exponentially many bits, so that approach won't work.
Instead, we can use an algorithm
called the power algorithm, which is also called repeated squaring where everything is done modulo-M
and we use the bits of
K to iteratively square and multiply in a way
that makes it all work.
So this one is more
expensive than the others, but we can still perform
modular exponentiation quite quickly on numbers
with many thousands of bits.
So how do the costs of these tasks compare with integer factorization?
If we start simple and
think about trial division where we first check to see if two is a factor of the input number
and then check three and so on, we'll end up with a pretty
expensive algorithm, big-O of N squared times
two to the power N over two.
Each division takes quadratic time and in the worst case, we'll need to search for prime factors up to the square root of the input number,
and that's where the N
over two is coming from. If we haven't found a
prime factor at that point, we can just stop because then
the input number itself must be prime.
This is extremely expensive because N appears as an exponent in this expression, which is to say that this
algorithm has exponential cost.
In contrast, all of the examples that we have in this box here have what we call polynomial cost where N gets raised to a power,
but that power is always a fixed number that doesn't grow as
the input length grows.
In these cases, the powers
are one, two, and three.
I'll come back to polynomial versus exponential cost in just a moment, but first, let's finish off
what we know about factoring.
Earlier I mentioned
the number field sieve, which is the best
factoring algorithm we have in terms of the way its cost scales.
In fact, the cost of this algorithm isn't actually rigorously proven because it's connected with some open questions about number theory,
but it is conjectured to have
a cost that looks like this.
This time the big-O is in the exponent, but I'm gonna sweep that
detail under the rug.
The key takeaway is that it's significantly better
than trial division because although N does
appear in the exponent,
it's raised to the power 1/3 and that translates to a much lower cost and that's why this algorithm
can handle numbers like RSA250, whereas trial division
most certainly can't.
It's still exponential though in the sense that a power of N is appearing in an exponent, and so, as a result,
it still can't handle
numbers like RSA1024.
Now let me say a little bit more about polynomial cost
versus exponential cost.
We say that an algorithm
has polynomial cost if its cost is big-O of N to the power B,
where B can be any positive number, but the key is that B has to be fixed, meaning that it doesn't change
as the input length end grows.
For the examples we saw a moment ago, meaning integer addition, multiplication, division, computing GCDs
and modular exponentiation,
we had that B was either
one, two or three.
So these are all
polynomial cost algorithms.
But when we say polynomial
cost more generally, B could be any positive number.
It could even be one million,
but it has to be fixed.
As a very rough abstraction, algorithms having polynomial
cost are typically viewed as representing efficient algorithms.
It's definitely an oversimplification, but as a rough guideline, you can think about a
polynomial cost algorithm
as somehow making use
of a problem's structure to construct a solution as opposed to a brute
force type of approach
or an exhaustive search
over a very large space.
Of course, an algorithm whose cost scales as N to the one million
on inputs of length N
would not reasonably
be viewed as efficient, and we wouldn't expect to be
able to run it on large inputs.
But still even an N to
the one million algorithm must be doing something clever that somehow reflects the structure
of whatever problem it solves to avoid the exponential scaling in cost that would be associated with
an exhaustive search over a large domain.
And in practice, the identification of a polynomial cost algorithm is really just a first
step towards efficiency.
If a problem is important
and someone discovers the very first polynomial
cost algorithm for it, maybe having a very large exponent,
you can be reasonably sure that algorithm designers
will find improvements that cause that exponent to come down.
In essence, you can
think about the existence of a polynomial cost
algorithm for a problem as demonstrating the feasibility
of solving that problem
on reasonably large inputs, but there still could be a lot of work required to reach true efficiency.
In complexity theory, it's typical to say that an algorithm's cost
scales sub-exponentially if the cost is big-O of two to the power N
to the power epsilon for every positive real number epsilon, and if it's not sub-exponential,
then it's exponential, or it could even be super-exponential like two to the two to the N,
which is doubly exponential,
but as long as the output
isn't super-exponentially long, every problem can actually be
computed by a Boolean circuit
having exponential cost as it turns out. So the important distinction here is between polynomial
and exponential cost.
We don't know of any sub-exponential cost classical algorithms for
integer factorization.
For example, the number field sieve's cost is not big-O of two to
the N to the epsilon when epsilon is 1/3 or less,
so it doesn't satisfy this definition.
It's undoubtedly a very clever algorithm, but it's still a sieve and we're still effectively searching
over a very large space to identify factors of a given number.
As we'll see in the next lesson, there is in fact a polynomial
cost quantum algorithm for integer factorization.
Shor's algorithm has polynomial cost and specifically it has qubit cost, similar to modular exponentiation.
Another class of problems that
you might be familiar with is the class of NP-complete problems.
I won't go into what NP-complete problems are in this lesson, but you can look them
up if you're interested.
It's conjectured that
none of these problems have sub-exponential cost.
That's essentially a circuit-based version of what's sometimes called the
exponential time hypothesis, but so far nobody's been able
to figure out how to prove it.
In fact, we can't even prove that there aren't linear cost algorithms for NP-complete problems.
It's just really tough, at
least as far as we know, to rule out the possibility
of a future discovery of an incredibly creative
algorithm for these problems.
Here's a figure that
illustrates the relationship between polynomial and exponential cost.
On the X axis, we have the input length to whatever problem we're thinking about, and the Y axis represents the
cost of solving that problem
or you can think about
it as the time required to solve the problem if you prefer.
An exponential cost algorithm
might scale like this.
For short inputs, the cost might not be particularly high, like factoring the
number 12, for instance,
but as the input length gets longer, the cost is eventually going to blow up.
A polynomial cost algorithm,
on the other hand, might have a scaling that looks like this.
The cost will still increase in general as inputs get longer, and it might even cost more than the exponential cost
algorithm for some inputs,
but eventually it's gonna
be a lot less expensive than the exponential cost algorithm and it doesn't blow up
in the same extreme way
that exponential cost algorithms do.
So if we imagine that we
have some maximum cost that we're willing to spend, or a maximum amount of time that we're willing to wait for an answer,
if you prefer to think about time, then the exponential cost algorithm will only work for inputs
up to a given length,
whereas, in general, the
polynomial cost algorithm will allow us to solve the
problem for larger inputs.
And that's why, for instance, we can easily compute GCDs for numbers with many thousands of
bits, but in the worst case,
we can't factor numbers of this size.
In the last part of the lesson, we'll turn our attention to implementing classical computations
on quantum computers.
More specifically, we'll
see that any computation that can be performed by a Boolean circuit can also be performed by a quantum circuit
at roughly the same cost. Moreover, this can be
done in a clean manner that's important if we
wanna run these computations
as sub routines inside of
larger quantum computations, and I'll explain what I mean by clean when we get further into the discussion.
We're going to make use of
Toffoli gates in this process.
Recall that Toffoli gates are controlled-controlled-NOT gates, so their action on standard basis states
is as you see here on the screen.
Notice that we can also
think about Toffoli gates as being like query gates
for the AND function.
That's not to say that they are query gates in a literal sense. As I mentioned at the start of the lesson, we're not working within the
query model at this point,
but rather, their action follows the same pattern as a query gate.
We can think of the binary values A and B as the inputs to the AND function and like a query gate,
these values get echoed
as part of the output and the value of the function, meaning the logical AND of A and B
gets XORed onto the bottom qubit. Now, we haven't included Toffoli gates in our standard gate set.
We could change our mind if we wanted to, but we don't really need to
do that because alternatively, we can implement Toffoli
gates using Hadamard gates,
T and T dagger gates
and controlled NOT gates like you see right here.
It's not at all obvious
that this particular circuit implements a Toffoli gate, but it does, and you can either take my word for it
or multiply everything out for yourself to get some extra practice, or you can just ask Qiskit or Python
or any software that multiplies matrices to do the multiplication for you.
And you can check out the
textbook content for the lesson to see this done using Qiskit.
Now we can move on to simulating Boolean gates with quantum circuits and all we'll need to
do this are NOT gates,
controlled NOT gates and Toffoli gates.
These operations are all deterministic in addition to being unitary and sometimes we describe
operations like this as being reversible, and in fact,
the study of reversible computation predates quantum computing and that's where this entire
procedure actually comes from.
The Boolean gates we need to
worry about are NOT gates, Hadamard gates and FANOUT gates,
And what we're going to show is that we can implement these gates, or simulate them if you
prefer, using NOT gates,
controlled NOT gates and Toffoli gates.
To be clear, what we
want are quantum circuits that allow us to compute the values of the Boolean gates that I just mentioned
when we give them qubits in
standard basis states as input.
For arbitrary quantum state inputs, the action will be determined
by linearity as usual.
We don't need to do anything
special with the NOT gates. NOT gates are NOT gates and they can be implemented directly.
And OR gates can be simulated
using Toffoli and NOT gates.
AND gates are easy, particularly in light of what I just said a few moments ago about Toffoli gates being essentially
query gate implementations
of the AND function.
To be precise, what we can do is to introduce a new qubit initialized to the zero state
and let that qubit be the
target of our Toffoli gate and let the two input
qubits be the controls.
Different names are given
to extra qubits like this, which are often introduced
into quantum computations and I'll call them workspace
qubits just to pick a name.
Our typical assumption on workspace qubits is that they start out in the zero state and we can often return
them to the zero state
when we're done with them, but not always.
In the diagram we have a cat zero inside of the dotted rectangle to indicate that the
initialization of this qubit
is part of the process, and if you don't have a
fresh qubit like this, you're not gonna be able
to do this simulation.
The bottom output qubit
is the one we care about because that's the result
of the AND operation and we're basically
done with the other two
so they can stay inside of the box.
In fact, you could even imagine that getting rid of these two qubits is part of the job of
simulating this AND gate,
kind of like garbage that
needs to be cleaned up.
But anyway, that's how we
can simulate an AND gate.
Now that we know how to do AND gates, we can do OR gates using
one of the De Morgan laws.
If you put NOT gates on the two inputs in the output of an AND
gate, you'll get an OR gate, so it's as simple as that.
And the last one is FANOUT, and for this one, all we
need is a controlled NOT gate along with a workspace qubit.
Specifically, if we
set the workspace qubit to be the target, we effectively just copy whatever standard basis state comes in,
so that acts like a FANOUT gate.
So we have all our gates.
And now that we have all of our gates, we can move on to circuits.
Let's suppose that we have
some Boolean circuit named C, and this can be whatever
Boolean circuit you choose
as long as it's composed of
AND or NOT and FANOUT gates.
We'll let T be the number of gates in C and we'll give the name F to whatever function it is that C computes.
So we can think of F as having the form that you see right here, where N is the number of input bits of C,
M is the number of output bits and sigma is the binary alphabet.
And what we do is to simply go one by one through the gates of C.
We leave the NOT gates alone and we replace the others with the simulations
that I just described.
So if C looks like this, then what we get is a circuit
R that looks like this.
In this diagram, all
of the workspace qubits we need for the simulations have been pulled out of their boxes and collected on the bottom.
So K is the total number of
workspace qubits we need, which is one for each of the gates of C except for the NOT gates.
For the output of R, we have the qubits that
correspond to the output of C, and here those qubits
are depicted on the top,
although it's not actually going to matter at the end of all of this
whether they're on top or not.
To be precise, assuming that we've run R on a standard basis state corresponding to an
arbitrary N-bit string X,
these M output qubits will be in the standard basis state
corresponding to F of X.
We also have all of the leftover qubits from the AND and the OR gates.
We still need to account for them, and if we gather them all together, they'll be in some standard basis state.
Whatever the standard basis state is has to be some function of the string X, and we're gonna give
that function the name G.
So G is a new function that's
determined by the gates of C that tells us what state
these leftover qubits are in
after R is run. G is the next letter after F, so that's one reason to
call this function G,
but another reason to call it G is because G is short for garbage.
These are all garbage qubits, and in particular, we
have two garbage qubits for each AND gate and for each OR gate.
The total number of gates
we need is big-O of T.
That's because for each gate of C, we need a bounded number of quantum gates.
The OR gate is the most expensive one. For that one, we need three NOT gates along with one Toffoli gate,
and a Toffoli gate costs us 15 gates from our standard gate set.
So that's at most 18 gates
in R for each gate of C.
If you wanted to optimize this, you could, but for the purposes of a
rough asymptotic analysis, we can simply say that
R has big-O of T gates.
So we've managed to
compute the same function F that the original Boolean
circuit C computed,
and we've done this at a cost that's linear in the size of C.
If all we care about is
computing this function F, then we're done.
But unfortunately, we do
have these garbage qubits and these garbage qubits
are generally going to ruin
the interference patterns that make quantum algorithms work if we try to use this
circuit R as a subroutine
inside of a larger quantum algorithm.
But we can in fact get
rid of this garbage, and the way that we can do
this is to make use of the fact that the circuit R can be inverted,
or in other words, we
can run it in reverse.
To illustrate how this works, let's imagine that we first run R and then we run R in reverse,
which we can express as R dagger.
To be clear about this, what it means is that we apply the gates
of R in the reverse order and we take the inverses
of each of the gates.
NOT gates, controlled NOT
gates and Toffoli gates are actually their own inverses, so if we're thinking in
terms of these gates,
then R dagger is really just R with the gates supplied
in the reverse order.
But in general, we can always run any unitary quantum circuit in reverse in the manner that I just described,
meaning that we apply the
gates in the reverse order and we replace each of the
individual gates by its inverse.
If we were to do this, we'd find that first running R and then running R in
reverse does nothing at all.
So if we started out in a standard basis state like we have here, then we would end in exactly the same standard basis state.
Of course, doing just
that isn't very helpful, but what we can do is we can introduce a bunch of extra qubits and specifically,
this is M qubits where M is the number of output bits of the circuit C.
These additional qubits could
be in any quantum state, but to explain how this works, we're going to assume that they're in a standard basis state
corresponding to some string Y. So Y is an M-bit string, and what we can do is to perform
a bunch of controlled NOT
gates like you see right here, which effectively XORs the string F of X
onto the string Y stored
in these bottom M qubits.
And so the output of
the entire computation is as it appears on the screen.
X and Y are arbitrary binary strings. X has M-bits and Y has M-bits, and we also need K workspace qubits.
When we run R, we compute F of X and that string is stored
in the top M qubits, but we also have a
bunch of garbage qubits,
so we XOR the output F of
X onto the bottom M qubits and then run R in reverse
to clean up the garbage.
I should point out that it's important that R is deterministic.
If these top M qubits could be instead in some superposition of
standard base of stats, this wouldn't work correctly,
but this does work when
R is deterministic.
So if we compare the quantum
circuit we just built to the original Boolean circuit C, we see that it basically
works in the same way
that a query gate works
for an arbitrary function.
There is a difference here, which is that we need
these workspace qubits to make it all work, but otherwise we've
effectively built a query gate
or a query circuit for whatever function it is that C computes.
We also managed, by the way, to return the workspace
qubits to their initial state, so they could in principle be reused
as workspace qubits for
subsequent computations.
If we want to, we can put a box around the entire quantum circuit and call it Q and the relationship to
C becomes more clear.
The circuit Q will be
bigger than C in general. We need a handful of quantum
gates in Q for each gate of C,
and we also need the controlled
NOT gates in the middle, but the number is still
linear in the size of C.
It should also be noted that this is a completely general procedure which works for any Boolean circuit, and we haven't tried at all to optimize Q.
For a specific circuit C, there might very well be
ways to reduce the size of Q, and that includes using methods
that reduce the number of
workspace qubits needed in case that's something
that we want to do, and that is the procedure for running
classical computations
on a quantum computer.
It's pretty simple, but it's an important
thing to be able to do.
In particular, now that
we know how to do this, we are free to make use of any classical computations we want
inside of quantum computations, provided that we follow this form where the input gets echoed and the output gets XORed
onto a bunch of qubits
just like we had for query gates.
The cost scales linearly. So for example, we can
create quantum circuits for problems like integer addition,
multiplication, division, computing GCDs and modular exponentiation, and this can all be done at the same asymptotic cost
as for Boolean circuits.
We do need workspace qubits to do this, but at least they're available to be reused again when
we're done with them.
One final remark that's worth mentioning is that this method provides us with a method to implement query gates,
which I alluded to in the previous lesson.
That is, if we have a query algorithm that takes some function F as input, and we have a way to compute
F with a Boolean circuit,
then we can follow this procedure to build a query gate for that function and then run our query algorithm on it.
Whether or not that's a useful thing to do depends on the query problem itself and what we're trying to accomplish, but in essence, this
construction provides us
with a way of connecting the query model to a more standard model of computation.
This is in some sense how Shor's algorithm for integer factorization works.
We're going to build
quantum circuits like this out of some of the arithmetic operations we talked about earlier in the lesson.
And by doing that, we
give quantum circuits the ability to evaluate those operations on super positions of classical states.
And as we will see, that allows us to factor integers efficiently.
That's the end of this lesson, which has focused mainly on establishing a foundation
for quantum algorithms in a standard non-black box
computational framework.
We talked about computational cost mainly through the lens of problems connected with basic number theory.
We discussed polynomial
versus exponential cost for computational tasks, and we saw how classical computations
can be implemented by quantum circuits in a clean garbage-free manner that allows them to be used as subroutines
inside of larger quantum computations.
I hope you'll join me for the next lesson where we'll see how Shor's algorithm puts these ideas to use, allowing us to factorize
integers at polynomial cost.
Goodbye until then.